non non nous kazemi mais totalement
impossible mais enfin monsieur
duchesneau pour toi non casimir tu ne
seras pas faire une chose pareille mais
pourtant vous en êtes capable il te
manque justement je n'en sais rien bien
sûr bien sûr mais immense talent me
permettre de tout affronter mais ce que
tu me demandes est particulièrement
délicat chérie tu as vu oui c'était trop
mais que font-ils
je n'en sais rien monsieur des snobs m'a
l'air très mécontents tu crois qu'ils se
disputent
j'espère bien que nous parce que nos
amis viennent d'arriver
bouchard bonjour je ne voulais pas vous
approcher le monsieur du snob et quasi
mieux pour savoir ce qu'ils se disent
parce que nous sommes très inquiet bon
je suis sûr que vous allez accepter pas
du tout être casé mire je n'oserai
jamais mais que vont penser vos amis et
surtout la contexte d'âpre l e vous
n'arrêtez pas de faire des discours ce
temps pourri et casimir qui sait
parfaitement comme moi qu'il n'y a pas
de contexte dans les enfants arabes et
c'est vous qui le dites oui non pas ça
ne regarde que moi en tout cas ne
venaient plus jouer les beaux parleurs
françois si nous allions les voir et
l'hôtel nous expliquer les raisons j'ai
dit mais alors si tous mourir faisons
semblant de n'avoir rien entendu mais
mais enfin les légendes en votre qualité
savent tout faire et n'ont peur de rien
tu crois vraiment casimir
non mais c'est vous qui le dites et puis
je serai là pour vous aider vous avez
confiance en moi en espagne
à vrai dire pas tout à fait casimir
enfin je crois que tu as raison les gens
de ma qualité ne doit pas se dérober
j'accepte bravo monsieur du jurassique
très fier d'eux bonjour casimir bonjour
monsieur du cinéma
bonjour m chers amis bonjour françois à
julie voulu préparé une petite surprise
ce n'est plus une surprise scherwiller
snob vous avez encore été faibles devant
l'assistance de casimir et vous avez
accepté un marché
on pas tout à fait monsieur du chinois
et moi même allons présenter une
conférence unique
ouais et alors
alors j'ai peur pour vous monsieur 10 ne
vous inquiétez pas à mon cher ami
cette fois ci il n'y a pas de danger je
n'ai accepté aucun marché malhonnête de
la part de casino guangxi casimir dit
nous allons présenter une conférence
c'est parce que je ne touche juste
l'accepter comme assistant il m'a
acceptée calculons très bien je ne dirai
plus rien su de ce noble et city se
nomme ma chère amie que je prends vous
quel sera le sujet de votre conférence
l'anatomie humaine c'est-à-dire les
différentes parties du corps de l'homme
et ça ne coûtera qu'un francs par
personne formidable je vais préparer le
banc et je paie pour tous les enfants du
genre seront ceux nés les enfants
venez vite nous allons assister à une
conférence de monsieur du seigneur est
allé lui sur le banc
voilà monsieur duchesneau a oui
êtes vous prêt à affronter vos
admirateurs de pas tout à fait casimir
j'ai le trac
as tu bien tous les dessins avec toi ou
moins oui mais grâce à ma malle magique
il n'y aura pas de problème à je te
remercie qu'il n'y ait de véritables
amis casimir casimir vient nous sommes 7
8 9 10 11
monsieur douce ne vous parlera
aujourd'hui dans l'autonomie du corps
humain pas l'autonomie quasi nuit
monsieur dix neuf vous parlera de
l'anatomie du corps humain
très bien mais mes très chers amis
objets très aigu pour ça se voit à oui
c'est vrai l'anatomie l'anatomie et
l'étude du corps humain
le corps humain le corps humain casimir
le corps humain oui le corps humain ou
et il a le corps humain oui mais voilà
merci que c'est bien oui voilà le corps
humain vous quasi mais ce n'est pas le
corps humain ah oui en effet ça c'est un
forte infectieuses et moi monsieur du
snop pour le corps humain le corps
humain je ne bougeais pas voilà le corps
humain merci oui voilà donc le corps
humain aura tout dit monsieur je ne sais
si c'est moi qui me suis trompé encore
cette fois il s'agit d'une carafe en
utah rock m'enfin kazim est la dernière
tentative monde le corps local main le
corps humain voilà à merci voilà le
corps humain oui je vais vous montrer
les différentes parties avec une
baguette avec une baguette casimir ah
oui la bague à quilmes baguette
voilà la baguette merci de ski voilà
donc je commence par la tête quand les
jeunes hommes arrêtés âgés ne bougeait
pas d'hosni l'imac
je me suis trompé bac est je vous ai
donné ma baguette magique un mouvement
de plus et tout disparaît c'est que tu
écoutes on va dire et fait attention ce
côté c'est encore une bêtise et je
m'arrête là notre baguette
merci oui voilà le corps humain mais je
te disais et voilà les différentes
parties il ya d'abord la tête c'est vrai
ici puis le trop et ça c'est vrai et les
quatre membres
les deux bras et les deux ans alors les
les bras sont composent
et de l'épaule du bras de la vendra du
poignet des cinq doigts à ses bras et
cette partie allez-y vous ailier de 6 10
cette parcelle d'arqués s'appelle c'est
à monsieur justin montrent la paume
mais vous parliez de la main toute
entière la main c'est safran sel c'est
la main merci beaucoup
et voici cette partie là s'appelle au tu
vois que je n'aurais pas dû accepter je
me trompe tout le temps vous êtes
complet nous n'ont cessé leur commission
du sénat.le coudes et les genoux et non
fondées ou les casinos vous croyez que
c'est le coude non leur union les
enfants la cagnotte à le faire tremper
mois ces notions nous bons risques et
cette partie s'appelle oui oui mais
maintenant le talent le talent oui je
crois que c'est ça le talent où il y
aurait cette partie de la cellule où je
le savais les enfants de la conférence
est terminée nous vous remercions
casimir pourrait casimir je crois que
j'ai été très mauvais non c'était pas
trop mal monsieur de ce nom vous avez
appris à un tas de choses et ça je peux
pas le nier ça c'est vrai oui oui de
suite pour vous ça ne coûtera qu'un
franc 20 ans mais les autres n'ont payé
qu'un front par personne ah oui mais eux
ont assisté à une conférence tandis que
vous vous avez pris une leçon
particulière que gémir